michael smith a brother from another
which uh follows our show every single
day here on nbc sports on on peacock
back here on the rich eisen show how are
you michael good what's up fellas what's
up
guaranteed yes it's gonna be a great day
i think it's i'm gonna guarantee this is
a great segment you know i'm with that
and then when it's not i'll get all the
questions what happened
yeah but if but if it's not
like so what like what's the downside of
guarantee like this this whole thing is
hilarious to me
not your commentary i just mean the fact
that it's like first of all it's not
really a guarantee
like he said we're going mike mccarthy
said we're going to win the game
in dc that's what he said we're going to
tito
of course it is watering down the
definition of a guarantee like joe
really name it is like that's not a
guarantee guys
it means that there's going to be some
level of accountability if we don't
all he did was say the quiet part out
loud like you just said it rich of
course he thinks we're going to win the
game like he just happened to say it but
that's what he should say and i don't
blame him i blame the reaction like mike
mccarthy saying we're going to win the
game that felt benign to me that was
that was completely innocuous like okay
fine nothing okay great great glad you
feel that way coach that means
absolutely nothing coming this weekend
does it but then for it to be a whole
story means like
just kind of unnecessarily feeding it
feeding into it and ron rivera is like
okay great you want to clap back but
you're clapping back at something that
wasn't
really that deep to begin with and do
they even have bulletin boards anymore
like bulletin board material that's kind
of like water cooler talks like we don't
even do that anymore we don't have
bulletin boards i don't know i just felt
like a whole bunch much ado about
nothing i don't know michael if the
cowboys lose this weekend you you don't
think you're going to hear from a bunch
of washington football team players
saying we heard that we know about that
how's that guarantee absolutely
absolutely and if any and
and michael lose because he guaranteed
it and then football team no got extra
fired up because the coach quarter quote
guaranteed it because the crew said
we're going to win so the washington
football team got up so okay so if
you're watching football team you got to
reach so deep for motivation against a
division rival with your playoff lines
lives on the line that you have to step
back and say that somebody's saying what
you yourself believe somebody saying it
out loud somehow offends you to the
point of getting you motivated to play
your arch rival michael if so you uh you
know uh i i think you you and uh i might
share similar qualities and
sensibilities if i said to you okay
something similar if somebody said
something similar to me about my show my
performance this thing that i have so
much care and love for with a bunch of
guys that i come to work with and ladies
that i come to work with every single
day and says uh we're less than because
they're going to guarantee that they're
going to have a better show or something
like that i'm trying to give some sort
of an analogy of course my show is still
going to be as good as it would have
been in my estimation without that
statement being made but i will
absolutely
have a little bit of pep in my step and
high step over how terrific the show is
you know what i mean like there is a
certain competitive nature and if
there's any figure
in professional sports that knows the
variables that goes into winning and how
difficult it is to win and how to to
make sure that winning has to be
um the most important thing and thus
anything else that could potentially put
a roadblock in front of it needs to be
avoided it's a head coach of a national
football league team
certainly the dallas cowboys
i was stunned i was stunned that he said
that
and that's what that's the part that
i'll agree with
is the juice worth the squeeze is the is
that what's the upside what's the upshot
of saying we're going to win what do you
get out of it
okay other than
unnecessary quote-unquote controversy
all right but i also counter that by
saying well what's the downside
it's kind of like going forward on
fourth down and saying well i believed
in my players so it's like if you say
we're gonna win and you don't win
is somebody really going to begrudge
mike mccarthy is okay forget about the
football team saying yeah we heard that
and it fired us up
but is anybody in dallas gonna say damn
it mike mccarthy why'd you have to say
that you thought you were gonna win the
game because don't you play to win the
game and in your analogy in terms of
like the show thing all right if i said
and again i'm just kidding here you go
[Laughter]
yes ma'am rich eisen is overrated
sucks he ain't interesting okay that's
so-called bulletin board material
but like it's not like you and i are
competing per se because we just try to
follow your show so it's a little bit
different when it's somebody that's
going out and their job comes at the
expense of somebody else's job one team
got to lose one team gotta win
ordinarily there are ties in the nfl for
those that are still uncertain about
that yes so ordinarily one team got to
win one team gotta lose
but it's just i just don't see why it
was it's he should be
criticized for saying something that
they all are wired to believe
to begin with you know what i mean it's
like it's almost like halftime speeches
man it's like we don't ever hear about
the halftime speeches that don't work
you know when they lose nobody talk
about what they said at halftime or what
they said saturday night before the game
so mike mccarthy said his team was gonna
win
okay great that's what we would i would
like to think you feel that way and if
the football team needs to manufacture
motivation
great good for you ultimately none of
it's gonna matter once the ball gets
kicked off yeah we're not a cliche so
you're saying we're we're not hearing
what mike zimmer's halftime speech was
last night today we're not gonna
right
i mean did it matter
should i ask alvin cook that one better
than halftime didn't even give a
half-time for crying out uh michael
smith here from brother for another on
the rich eisenhower you don't suck by
the way you're really good i feel the
same way i feel the same way and i never
believed that
whatever okay uh so what what do you
make of the lakers man i mean
that that where it's not christmas time
yet there's still much time to go but i
mean now we've got
uh what is it now 26 27 games
uh or 25 games of of actual
playing right this week games 25-27
and it's mediocre there's just no other
way to put it it is average it is
average basketball that we're seeing
so what do you think that actually might
be generous at various points because i
got all excited the other day i promised
that i would get off the roller coaster
and i got all excited about them beating
the celtics i'm not a lakers fan by the
way for the record but i gotta you know
i i started to think oh maybe this is
the team we thought that they could be
maybe they're rounding into form
at both ends russell westbrook has been
playing better lately they've been
defending better lately you know maybe
the team against the celtics albeit you
know the celtics aren't world beaters
and we're missing jaylen brown maybe
they're starting to find themselves a
little bit and they're going to lose to
the john morantlist although very
competitive lately memphis grizzlies um
i i think
they'll be i think they'll end up
somewhere between
the finals favorite that they were
and this mediocre version that we're
seeing now i don't think that this is
who they are and i don't think they'll
be worse before it's all said and done
barring injury if that makes sense so
we're seeing the floor
i think this is the floor and maybe i'm
being naive but i do think this is the
floor because even within the
20-something game sample size we now
have and you're right it's still not
christmas unofficial start of the season
like i think you have to parse that and
say well how many games were they
missing lebron
how many games have they met or they all
of them you know um
uh they've been missing some key players
you know um
so i
you know i i wouldn't necessarily make
any grand proclamations about them
um right now i'm trevor reason so i was
trying to remember trevor ariza
that's about it yeah i mean that
rotation hasn't been complete and not to
mention it it should be a work in
progress integrating a russell westbrook
into a team
that has two players already through
whom the offense should run in lebron
james and anthony davis so work in
progress to begin with but when you
don't all have you have all your tools
at your disposal
a longer work in progress right now if
i'm a lakers fan i'm just going to sit
back and look forward to and enjoy
winning time because that trailer was
fired yeah that's obvious
no i know that's the problem is you know
none of those guys are going to be
walking through that door but they do
have an all-time great in lebron james
who did seem to chafe a bit uh last
night when talking about all the
different rotations that vogel's going
through just you know in search of the
right one
that they're you know that he's playing
with a bunch of guys that he's trying to
figure things out because
there's no set rotation there's no real
set
uh five in a way outside of the four you
know ogs in a way
um and right now the lakers are are
are putting themselves in position for
another play-in game you know um if that
happens
for a second straight year that would be
wild what do you think about the blazers
do you think um uh damien lillard is
gonna wind up uh elsewhere
by
next year something what do you think i
i don't believe so like i've
there are two stories this week that
came up uh for various reasons that i
feel like you should strongly consider
retiring
one is the when will tom brady retire
story okay two
is
when will damian lillard
actually ask out
now that doesn't mean that
it can't get so bad until he and whoever
is the full-time general manager and
jody allen can't come to some kind of
agreement
about
what's best for him and the organization
mutually
but even though it kind of felt like he
was
headed in that direction in the off
season with some of the things he said
after the nuggets lost
i don't think damian lillard and we just
gotta accept this damian lillard is not
that dude that's gonna say
man you know what this ain't gonna work
here y'all gotta trade me to a contender
i'm going ring chasing he's he's never
been that dude he's not that dude
and everybody else holding their holding
their breath thinking he's gonna be that
dude like this guy is 10 toes down
professionally and personally in
portland
you know for a variety of reasons a lot
of them off the court like that's his
home and that's where he wants to be no
matter how much we've come so far in the
rings culture
that
not only are we okay
with guys
forming super teams or or chasing rings
with contenders but now when somebody
doesn't do it we look at them sideways
like yo what's wrong with you man get
with the program you're supposed to be
going trying to get with the lakers or
the net so it's a former super team
somewhere why are you what's taking you
so long i don't think he's going to do
that to me
it really comes down to
does and you and i have had this
conversation a lot we've all had this
conversation up quite a bit fellas
is
do we do does daryl mori blink
because i think if if i'm gonna start
shaking it up in portland
i know he's going through a lot right
now he's got a baby on the way he's got
a collapsed lung i think it starts with
cj mccollum i think they're too
redundant and have been for a while in
the backcourt i think it starts with can
portland put together a deal
that gets ben simmons
to portland and improves that defense
and if and when damian lillard decides
and the organization collectively
decides
that he needs to move on somewhere else
whether it's we don't want to extend you
or it's run its course and you want to
go for a fresh start against his
you know his reputation then at least
you have ben simmons to build iran does
that make sense sure does sixers are 14
and 12 so i don't know if that's
desperate enough
but um they're certainly not at the top
of the pack like they were last year how
would you how would you solve it in
portland where would you start i don't
know man no i i know the way my god
chris brockman would just tell tell
lillard uh you're out you know
like
that he that he is easily the best uh
chip that you can cash in for
multiple multiple picks to try and just
restart i just don't see that
like take a look at the bad guy type
thing like okay i'll i'll do the
uncomfortable thing and i'm going to
trade you damien lord like pretty much
but i i think that's a non-starter in
that town they have a different fan base
than most over in portland um you know
and and that i i think they want lillard
i think lillard wants them and they're
just going to try and figure it out i
don't know how you do
because it is it is a very difficult
puzzle certainly with a new coach there
and and phillips
and it's just not working it's terrible
and mccollum it might be the uh the
piece that you trade if you can and i
hate to refer to him as such or the
player that you trade um
but he's hurt i don't know you got to
play through it let let lillard come
back sunday as you know the report is
and see if that gets better can he just
carry the team by himself well he hasn't
been playing well i don't know i've
always been hurt bury that you know he's
been hurt and not playing well so it's
not as though
you know this is this is the daimler
that we left in the playoffs last year
so he bears some responsibility in it as
well and i've been definitely you know
uh talking about the brady retirement
story this week not because i'm trying
to drum anything up to be honest with
you uh it's because uh i saw a quote in
a piece in sports illustrated that i've
never heard of it that i'd never heard
i've never heard out of his mouth before
you know which one the one where he says
that uh that it when when he called
willing winning a relief
it's not like the joy it's a relief
because when you win sometimes just
winning isn't good enough for you
because you expect perfection
and and that's what i hear from people
that just you know suddenly decide it's
just not worth it which is something
that i've never
thought i would ascribe to him
you know i never like the winningest the
guy who's won more no one's ever going
to win like brady ever again right and i
feel i feel very safe in saying that you
know that that generations will come and
go uh you know knocking on wood on this
planet and you know where football can
be played and will never never ever see
a winning like they they could rename
the trophy the brady trophy one day and
and and people shouldn't bat an eyelash
with all due respect to the lombardi
family and he's calling it a relief that
that kind of stood out to me what kind
of things so that was the story i was
talking about because you got sports
person of the year yeah um and and
that's what i was referring to i was
like just the idea of
when he's gonna call it quits so the
regression comment jumped out to me
because
right he's like i don't want to get bad
well he's the best quarterback in the
league right now and he's about to beat
mvp again so does he regress to where he
was if he if conventional wisdom says
he's playing as well if not better than
ever
at 44 right regression only looks like
him being
not old as an age tom brady but old as
in previous iteration of tom brady
from a physical standpoint he's not
going to get dumber per se so from a
physical standpoint
he's got enough mental acumen to be able
to offset
whatever arm strength he may lose but
his arm is as strong as ever so that was
the part that jumped out to me but even
in terms of the relief thing i didn't
read it as a negative i read it as
people like tom brady are driven by that
like it's almost like a
it's like a burden that they enjoy
bearing if that makes sense right i know
but then the enjoyment finally wears off
because the that's that's that's the
whole point about it is that is that you
know how it works in this business it's
it's either it's either your choice to
retire or father times choice that you
retire and he doesn't want to be in the
middle of a season where father time
makes that choice for him
i think first of all
talk about that father time is holding
the l like that fight i was saying
yesterday we can't keep telling my
father time is undefeated no father time
has lost and we he doesn't just get to
fight you know forever like he's lost to
tom brady in the event that tom brady
actually does decide to retire that does
not go in the ledger as a victory for
father time because the fact that these
players just said 44 counts as a win
that's number one number two i think
he's addicted to it maybe there's some
sort of masochism involved i don't know
but i think
you know and it's funny because we
thought that the misery was was a was a
product of strictly bill belichick
they're more alike than maybe the
conversation around his departure would
lead us to believe like oh he was just
so tired of of being taken for granted
and being being a miserable environment
in new england it's like no that's
that's how brady's wired too so i think
that misery is what keeps him going if
he ever started to feel a sense of joy
about winning it listen i'm just i'm
spitballing here because i don't know
what it's like to be tom brady but i
imagine if he ever started to feel a
sense of joy about winning
joy may
come dangerously close to satisfaction
you understand what i'm saying i do like
i think i think the the and most great
say this whether it's jordan whether
it's brady a lot of great athletes and
competitors say it's not i think pat
riley especially it's not the winning
it's the you know i feel better the
losses hurt more than the winds feel
good right exactly i think that's what
drives them though i think that's what
makes them great i don't think it's a
negative i don't think it's going to
drive him to retirement i think it's
what drives him to keep playing is that
sorry lexus but that relentless pursuit
of perfection michael smith everybody
from brotherhood
uh thanks as always michael appreciate
it let's do this was that a great
segment i thought it was uh i i however
in my in my own you know potential this
is my insecurity it's my problem so this
is an mp not a not a yp not a it's a my
problem i feel like over the last couple
times you've called in i've made you
talk about uh topics you you find uh
less than you know i mean you'd like to
know like you want to retire these two
topics and i brought them up to you and
we chopped it up and then you know
i mentioned something from another guy
from another network who shares the same
last name as you you brought that up
that was a problem i just want to make
sure
if you want to set the agenda next time
you just let me know let's talk some
topics that you're like you're into
so i appreciate it i see what you're
trying to do there rich i'll see what
you're trying to do that rich i love our
topics i love our chat right back i hope
you and your listeners do as well let
them be the judge let me
okay there you go very good
have a great show later on thanks for
calling michael all right man i'll be
good michael smith everybody brother
from another uh follows us on nbc sports
on peacock hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here